people will not understand what it means
to get banged on
yeah yeah and it's like dj head had to
educate me when i moved out here and be
like hey look
yeah like you know you like i know
you're like dude he gave me the whole
hot run down he was like look at the
t-hat on you
what does this have mean it mean it mean
gangster [ __ ] basically it's crazy
i mean and it's blue so i literally i
got this happening
me and freddie were in tray we were in
austin texas and i bought this hat yeah
yeah but we ain't we're in l.a now i
know i know so so it's crazy to get
rough bro
bro head had to give me the whole
breakdown he's like look bro you can't
wear yankees hats
unless you're in the valley no he's like
you he's like astro hats out
yeah he's like he gave me the whole [ __ ]
and i was like [ __ ] i would tell him i
was telling les
i was you know
people think you're a [ __ ] hoover
well yeah we don't care if you're an
astro fan or not you gotta leave that
[ __ ] somewhere else bro cause
we gonna spin off and [ __ ] gonna get on
you where you fro check it out all that
that's when they get check it out when
they hit you with that bro you better
just get out the way or you feel me
it's when they get bad yeah it's wild
because like i was like well look i'm
from arizona what about a diamondbacks
hat
he's like i think you're good with that
he's like that and just a plain black
might wake up in a bad mood and you
could have a
[ __ ] you got the a hat on he could
have that [ __ ] don't even mean nothing
that [ __ ] might just be like
homie what that a stand for like just
because he in a bad mood like bro
you be like best so what [ __ ] all that
you feel me take that [ __ ] off and the
[ __ ] be really in you know what
i'm saying on a bad day hey
hey head told me he was like look if
anyone ever tries to bang on you
just start acting super pissed off like
you just got into a fight with your girl
man [ __ ] this business [ __ ] just left
me here i'm waiting for my uber i'm
gonna kill this
head gonna get you [ __ ] up you're
about to tell the [ __ ] man i'm
not
from here you feel me yeah i'm not from
over here i'm from
i'm from arizona but like a
[ __ ] like all right all right
you know what i'm saying am i out of
town pilots be coming here and they'd be
like man i can't wear red i can't wear
blue
like bro all you got to do is speak you
sound like you from florida or something
like man ain't nobody worried about you
but it's only in these sections like
certain areas we're in north hollywood
bro you know i could walk down the
street ain't nobody gonna say nothing
you know what i'm saying if you're in
certain areas south of [ __ ] wilshire
or some [ __ ] like that
really south of uh when you pass [ __ ]
um
what is that [ __ ] like olympic south of
the olympics make sure you it's you can
get banged on
me you will be at the 7-eleven the gas
station yeah
all that burger spots you know that's
that's where it goes up at
you